bon je vais vous prendre l'avion je vais
antibes avait pas très souvent de mettre
en avant de vivre oui sa première fois
mais qu'est ce qu'ils fabriquent à
peut-être rencontré une fille du
quartier mais pourquoi pas la reine
d'angleterre
aimer romantisme j'avoue je me suis
jamais posé la question noire mamans
souvent besoin des navettes en chaise
roulante comme ça je m'appelle avant et
je m'appelle paul joe drake marier avec
vous money dit
c'est vous bien tout ce qu'il faut pour
avoir un enfant
mais ne se sont pas des choses qui se
demande la tap j'ai peut-être mon avis
est donné non vous l'avez pas
quelqu'un en vol se marie avec quelqu'un
du métro
à ton avis qui gagne pas tout le monde
puisque propriétaire de la rolls et
obtient enfin ce qui n'a jamais pu
acheter l'amour
j'ai vraiment heureux avec cette attaque
on
je m'appelle havas jour j'ai défaut
l'appareil solidarité
à 20 qu'avez-vous fait aujourd'hui tf
vous fait aujourd'hui je me suis promené
la petite pub vient de sortir
[Musique]
m
non
swann vous je ne tiens plus mon ami
c'est que les folles
avatar aujourd'hui
[Musique]
faudrait faire un test adn
imaginez
si elle à l'hygiène de la pauvreté
[Musique]